welcome to this video yeah and Merry
Christmas yeah I think I got this right
this video should be released on
Christmas Eve so it's nothing it's okay
to wish you a Merry Christmas so let's
see you this is F for early f4 bird
opening yeah i know that this line here
with Quinn b6 the Sun supposed to be
quite okay it can make me play with your
form yeah night interesting hmm Jeff I
don't really mind the Queen trade of
course you actually never do do mind
that that you get this double porn but
he didn't do it let's see John maybe
night to have 67 at least he can castle
now but he has set up a somewhat
somewhat unconventional stone wall here
with g3 plate of course it's the
position is so close that it does not
matter that much that he has played g3
and Bishop g2 kind of curious not
castling simply is there I draw back to
that
where's this night going actually
preparing c4 I don't know night-night
a3s some kind of curious maybe night c22
III this is the idea 93 years some move
that I probably wouldn't have considered
it seems like that it wants to put the
night over I wonder if I should go see
five simply opening up the pollution
here maybe not so much I wonder if maybe
you can really take dahiya looks really
greedy but possible okay let's just get
this to f6 where it belongs looking at
the you form and you fall on yeah okay
right here and now not Bishop f5 to e4
is the is the next step but I would love
to do is to exchange this vision p.m. on
e4 against his bishop this is the ideal
scenario and I think I'll manage that
now we traits Queens interesting
yeah you almost never mind that double
porn because it's not a weakness at all
and in fact quite often it gives
additional options on the a phone so
it's definitely quite quite nice for me
this position so yeah now it's not even
threatening f5 going for this possibly
night c4b five tries to keep his pawns
on dark square so that he keeps his some
bad Bishop him let's see one Bishop
let's enter him
the other night supposed to go to see
form yeah here we go threatening I'm 92
we're quite quite funny until I actually
would consider to just heck this an idol
he see it's not paying attention to 92
maybe he's intending to play night to
see Five somehow okay anyway I think I
can take here first to simplify things
if he takes with the night only five now
yeah okay so i can do this now i am
winning the exchange if he goes night c5
now i have rugae seven and then be 62 to
cover it i will 97's is a problem i'll
go b6 okay i can take first year let's
take first and then think about it if i
go be sick cm 97 I am not so gradient I
should I should keep this covered maybe
just here
hmm interesting now I will dig I think
it can only help me if the position is
opened up a little bit more so I don't
mind to to capture so be 6a I guess v6
preventing 95 he possible annoyance
could be night to be for attacking the
c6 pawn which is a weakness but I don't
see really see how it it can be done I
mean it's not the end of the world if
the night appears there of course I'm
going to open up as much as possible ok
he helps me with that
yeah okay child let's keep the light out
now advanced with the king the night
coming to e5 will always simply be be a
bit to be taken you from winning king
and corn and game
yeah we had to wear where to go I
shouldn't blunder the rupiah that's very
important and I shouldn't allow the five
years at least not so so easily yeah
maybe still shy give this check and then
just go ahead here with the with a king
d 5 it's not so dangerous check
yeah now probably kingi for him
ultimately playing rook f2 and mopping
up the the queenside time morning yeah
that should be or should be enough
really shy one light maybe I didn't
really play it play it so well
technically but two matched it it still
shouldn't be winning i invade with King
III but it feels like I know it a little
bit too much share yeah I want to keep
the pawns for the moment there's no
reason to to give him any material check
here I will gladly and transform that's
the sea point is just promoting now
white person yeah I had a really nice
position here out of the opening I mean
this kind of setup here with g6 and
Queen B 6 is quite okay against the bird
opening if you are looking for a
low-maintenance way to play this is some
something that fits the bill it prevents
castling so it's a bit a little bit
disturbing for wide and I'm also
checking here I am I mean it can be
risky business to take it sometimes but
it is something that should be kept in
mind I don't know I think 93 years also
move here but I really don't know it
very well this is cannot troubled like
very much I mean
Queen takes be success is never really a
never really on and more something like
fo I mean I probably can even even do
this yeah with the night coming here
should be a very nice actually yeah he
went with deform ultimately but this is
definitely okay for black yeah those
weaknesses on on e4 it's just a very
decent stone wall structure or let's say
playing against the stone what here for
black is a very nice option night a
three c2 is a little bit strange to be
honest I don't know what them what the
point is because the night never really
got to good squares iam I don't mind the
straight here at all and after this I'm
really comfortable in put the structure
here b5 this is a very good structure
for black you always have them have the
night jump and I have those those are
our weaknesses and there is nothing to
compensate for that so it's very nice
and now you overlook this 92 or or maybe
he had a different idea about the
position that he had some compensation
but it really didn't materialize so yeah
here I mean it's really just in exchange
I think I could have played it better
certainly yeah rookie to for instance he
has strong but okay I mean you have to
exchange the only thing that you have to
be aware of besides the the second fact
that this is a night and there are those
Forks is that you don't trade to too
many poems and at the end you are you're
stuck there with night against truck but
I think it wasn't really a something
that will serve us on him yeah I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching